[Musique]
c'est l'histoire improbable d'un
dentiste devenu révolutionnaire à
première vue amet des semelles lion mène
une vie ordinaire
[Musique]
les patients se succèdent devant un
médecin attentif et méticuleux mais
Ahmed est beaucoup plus qu'un simple
dentiste
sa vie a basculé le 8 janvier 2020
lorsque le vol ps752 a été abattu par
l'Iran peu après son décollage de
Téhéran les 176 passagers sont morts y
compris la femme et la fille d'Ahmed
il nous reçoit au deuxième étage de sa
clinique il y a 3 ans c'était la salle
de jeux de sa fille rira
il y avait un tapis de jeu et des
poupées se souvient-il depuis l'accident
d'avion cette pièce est devenue son
quartier général des rapports des photos
des boîtes de paperasse autant de signes
de son interminable quête pour obtenir
justice
depuis septembre la lutte d'ahme des
smileys
le dentiste a joué savoir à celle de
milliers d'Iraniens pour demander la
chute de la République islamique
toute cette douleur nous est revenue
explique Ahmed la mort de la jeune
iranienne
propulser le pays dans un mouvement de
protestation qui ne s'essouffle pas une
lutte identique à celle que mène Ahmed
depuis presque 3 ans
de rester les bras croisés Ahmed et
l'association des victimes du vol ps752
décide d'organiser une première série de
manifestations au Canada le rappel est
entendu partout dans le monde
du jour au lendemain le dentiste se
retrouve à coordonner des manifestations
dans plus de 150 villes
le mois dernier il se rend à Berlin il
prend la parole devant 80 000 personnes
venu soutenir les opposants iraniens le
dentiste canadien devient une figure de
proue du mouvement de contestation et
parvient à unifier une opposition
jusque-là diviser une pression énorme
pour un père endeuillé qui se voit
surtout comme une personne ordinaire
[Musique]
dès le début j'ai compris qu'il était
spécial se souvient le documentariste
babac payami qui a produit un film sur
Ahmed
lui-même d'origine iranienne n'a pas été
surpris de voir le dentiste devenir un
symbole du mouvement de contestation
il est si bien sans arrêt par le régime
iranien un tel point qu'il s'inquiète
pour sa sécurité
de continuer la lutte pour sa femme et
sa fille qui aurait joué leur voix à
celle des manifestants iraniennes si
elles étaient encore là
[Musique]
révolutionnaires pour se donner du
courage un homme qui a perdu ce qu'il
avait de plus cher et qui est incapable
de faire son deuil sans avoir obtenu
justice celui qui continue de
s'accrocher au rêve devenir en libre